the biggest hack to stop caring about
other people's opinions to stop living
other people's version of your life and
to start actually feeling happy and
proud of yourself is to figure out what
you stand for your single most important
core value I believe that everybody has
a single most important core value and
when you figure that out it gives you a
lot more clarity a lot more Direction a
lot more confidence and allows you to
start to do things that you never
thought were possible all of a sudden
that idea that you've got a oh my gosh I
could do this thing but then never
taking action on it things start to
happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and buil to serve and
we go through the process of figuring
out your one word or you're who who are
you what do you stand for what is that
single most important core value hey
it's Nina Carmichael and we made these
videos because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of of more and you
need that Push by surrounding yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
carmichel and learn how to stop caring
about others opinion
enjoy if you've understood the concept
of hey I need I need to have a core
value I need to know what I stand for
I'm tired of being on on quicksand I'm
tired of living other people's version
of my life okay great how do I figure it
out do I just pick one at random do I
just read a book like how do I actually
figure out what I stand for well asking
yourself that question who your favorite
teacher growing up was and why I think
is critical think about it you've had
how many teachers in your life think
about your school elementary school high
school uh University if you went to at
College other teachers you've had you've
had lots of teachers growing up and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walked past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they
were because they had no
impact but there's always that one
teacher that stood out there's one
teacher that stood out for
you why it wasn't because they taught
you grade eight math it's because they
made you feel different as a human they
gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
far Madame far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
on a day-to-day
basis what she taught me was to believe
in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of
uh high
school and she would meet with me every
week before before school started once a
week we'd sit down we chat we talk about
life we talk about uh school we talk
about where I was at we talk about what
was on my mind and in those
conversations she made me feel like I
could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in
myself and in that last year I went from
being a b and c student to straight 90s
straight
A+ I was still the same guy I still had
the same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had it was just that
belief in me that she gave me that
allowed me to go off and start to
perform more so I think that's the most
important question you can ask another
one you can look at is what was your
favorite movie growing up and why what's
your favorite movie of all time why
there's so many movies that you've
watched most of them you don't remember
but there's one that that sticks out
that really stands out for you in some
in some way for some reason my favorite
movie is Sea Biscuit it's about this
horse that is way too small it's about
this jockey that's way too big it's
about this owner that's bankrupt and
somehow they all find each other and
start winning a whole bunch of races
when when they they shouldn't be you
know and it's based off of a true story
and it ended up lifting a nation that
people love this Underdog Story and it's
a story of belief same thing it's a
story of
belief we all at least for me I I love
the idea of being that Sea Biscuit or
being the jockey or being the owner and
helping not just each other believe in
themselves but also the nation for the
audience for the fans helping them
believe in
themselves and so if you started asking
those questions if you started thinking
about who are the people that make you
come alive that make you feel like
you're a better person or what are the
resources or what are the YouTube
channels or Instagram accounts or books
or podcasts or shows what are the things
that have made you come alive what are
the things that have made you feel like
you could do
more and then next to each one write
down a couple of words so your favorite
teacher growing up who was it and then
why three words to explain why your
favorite movie of all time and then
three words why and what you'll find is
as you do this
exercise you'll see some similar
patterns you'll see some words pop off
the page you'll see that same word come
up a couple
times that's your who that's your single
most important core value that's what
you still need more of in your life
right now and that's what you want to
give to the world the other great part
about it is that will be with you for
life this isn't something that we want
to change this is who you are this is
your best version of
you at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level when you
figure out your most important core
value your who your one
word it's still what you need right now
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level and it's what you want to get to
the people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big
message but some people like nah who was
just here she doesn't have a big message
but she wants to help the closest people
to her we all want to feel like what we
do matters we all want to feel like
we're having an impact on people whether
the closest people to us are to the
world but we're stuck and we're lost and
we need guidance and if if you feel like
you have all these ideas but you don't
know how they all make
sense and you don't know that you feel
like it could be something but you don't
know how to get
there there's not enough momentum
happening it's because you're not in
touch with your single most important
core
value here's an example if I'm
struggling to do something I'm
struggling to get on stage to speak I'm
struggling to turn on the camera to make
a video for you I'm struggling to launch
my next project you know I get an idea
and then I say oh I can't do that what
do I
need at the end of day what do I really
need like what's the thing that's going
to turn that idea into actual action I
do more
belief and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more in yourself
because that's at the core of who I
am and when I can catch it then it gives
me the courage to go off and do it to
record the video to get on say to launch
that project to say yes to say yes to
say yes I think of uh Alex who helps me
run tronto dance also his who was
belong he needs to belong more with
himself and he needs to spread more
belong to the world and whenever he's
not happy and whenever he's not
following through and whenever he is not
hitting his goals and doing the work is
because he doesn't feel like he belongs
doesn't feel like he belongs to himself
and he doesn't feel like he spreading
belong to the world if you are
stuck if you are going too
slow if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you the thing that is
missing is you not following through on
who you say you want to be you're not
matching that potential
how you make it practical is to figure
out you're
who because every time you come back to
that and say I just need more of X I
need more hope I need more freedom I
need more belief I need more belong I
need more love I need more care for
myself and then to spread it to the
world and when you can feel
that when you can actually feel
that it'll dramatically change how you
show
up all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a
year you've released the chains you've
given yourself
Wings you've given yourself the
permission to actually go off and do the
scary thing that's inside you because
now you know who you are figure out your
one word figure out your who watch your
life change number two believe you go as
far as you believe you can go when the
people around you say you're crazy when
you're putting in massive effort but
you're not getting the results where you
sit alone and wonder did you just make
the biggest mistake of your life by
starting this business that is the time
when most people quit and you need to
believe more because if you love this
thing if you know that it's going to
impact people and you give up too soon
you will regret for the rest of your
life knowing that you were capable of
more and you just quit on it a little
too early so I look at my new book as an
example I did my tour Across America met
with entrepreneurs all across America
and found that people were struggling
with the same thing they want to know
how do I find what my purpose is and
turn it into a lucrative business every
city that I went to even though that was
not the topic I was covering it came up
over and over and over and over again 23
different cities and so I thought I'm
going to write a book on this this is
going to be my next book I'm going to
take people through the process because
my process works and it helped people
live in in 10 15 minutes and they're
getting they're getting new ideas and
and results and here we go like they
they understand what path they need to
take finally they have Clarity on what
to do next and so I told my agent and my
lit agent like this is the next book I
want to
write we told Publishers this is the
next book I'm going to write and from
the start it's been this big pull it's
been it's been fighting it's we don't
like the title we don't like the concept
no we're not going to publish it no
we're not going to publish it and I want
to do it by January cuz I want to do my
next tour across the rest of the United
States East Coast Texas Mexico I want to
do my next tour so I want to have my
book in stores by that time and it's
been this rough slog where if I didn't
believe in myself that this was so
important with the people who are
looking at it saying no we don't like
this concept nah it's been written
before now this method we don't believe
in it's easy to quit it's easy to to
give up it's easy to say forget it I
just know that it's going to work I know
that the process helps people I've seen
it with my eyes across 23 cities over 90
days I wrote the draft of the book and I
gave it to some beta readers and the
number one piece of advice from people
who've read both my books so you're one
word and then this like this is this is
the better book this is the best book
you've written so far including myself
self-published ones and so what do I do
I've got these people who are my
audience who love it and then these
people who aren't my audience but who
make decisions saying nah we don't
believe in it I'm not going to
quit I got to keep going I got to do my
tour there's there better be some crazy
good reason for me not to do my tour
right even if I have to self-publish it
now I'm pretty close to making my deal
making it all happen and and getting
timelines and all that but we don't have
a signed contract yet and anything can
happen we're pushing the timelines
because I'm pushing the timelines
because otherwise this thing could drag
on forever when you have an idea that
you love that you know can have a huge
impact that's just taking longer than
you hoped it would when people are
telling you that it's crazy and that
it's stupid and that who are you to go
off and do this thing if you love it you
have to double down on it you have to go
in on it you have to be open to getting
help but if that door closes you try to
find another one and that's the story of
every successful person you're trying to
do something
different the book you're writing the
product you're making the songs you're
singing the service you're providing is
not a photocopy of anybody else's it's
Unique it's different it's you that's
the best part of it and so because it's
different people don't understand it
especially the people closest to you who
are in something totally different they
have their set stable get a job
mentality and likely hate their life and
here you are trying to do something
totally outside the
norm so you're going to get a lot of
people who crap on your ideas but if if
people who hate their life are then
giving you career advice why would you
want to follow that have they done what
you're trying to do no so so do the
opposite and so I think it's really
important to find ways to believe in
yourself in these dark moments when you
don't have a support system when you
don't have people telling you that
you're great when when you're doubting
yourself you need to have a method to
help you believe in yourself I've got
three things that I use I'm going to
share them with you and hopefully they
have an impact for you too number one is
create your own 254 so I have a bunch of
series on this channel called 4 where
every day for 254 days I send you a
morning video around the topic that you
care about so for this one Sarah
Blakeley it's around girl boss so if
you're a woman entrepreneur every day
for 254 days I'm going to send you a
morning video for free that profiles a
different successful woman entrepreneur
so that if you're ever doubting yourself
if you ever feel not good enough because
you're a woman entrepreneur whatever
story is going through your head every
day for 254 days you've got an example
that it is possible you don't think it's
possible you don't believe but but then
here's this person who's done it and
then another one and then another one
and then another one and it starts to
shift your mindset that maybe it's
possible for me too to spread more
belief now I've only done I don't know
six 254s or so you create your own what
makes you feel like you believe in
yourself the reason why it's 254 days is
because that's the maximum number of
days it takes of consecutive action to
build a habit you want to drink water
every day it'll take at least 18 days
the average is 66 days to build a habit
and the worst is 254 days the slowest
learner takes 254 days to build that
habit so I want to be with you every
step of the way in the in the courses
that I'm making that are free you make
your own I made my channel for me cuz I
want to be around these successful
people I want to learn from Sarah blle
every day I want to learn from Oprah
Winfrey every day I want to learn from
Howard Schultz every day these people
that I look up to and respect I want to
be around them every day it's why I
created my content selfishly for myself
and then I share with you guys so if you
want more belief
maybe my channel is good enough for you
maybe you're already noticing the shift
maybe you're part of the one of the 254
series and you're watching every day and
I get emails every day from people
saying I notice myself getting more
confident I notice myself getting more
bold I notice myself having more belief
in myself right but maybe I'm not the
source for you maybe you have to go
somewhere else awesome what's the thing
that makes you feel more believ and then
inject that into your daily routine
every single day because if you're doing
that for 254 days you will come out on
the other side a totally different
person you won't recognize the person
who you are you can look back on your
life say man that person 254 days ago is
totally different than who I've grown to
become right it's the it's the
caterpillar becoming a butterfly and I
want that for you so you need to create
your own program number two is use a
Quincy Jones Rule and Quincy Jones we
did a top 10 on him where he had this
beautiful line where he said not one
drop of my self worth depends on your
acceptance for me I love that line so
much it's so true because so many of the
things that make us doubt ourselves are
other people's opinions and so the fact
that not one ounce not one drop not one
bit of my self-worth comes from your
opinion of me your thoughts about me
your judgment of me is not something
that you can just switch on I don't
think but the more you listen to it the
more you tell yourself that you start
noticing that you care a little bit less
about people's opinions and that's one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow is they don't care about
what the haters think about them they
don't care about what other people's
opinions are even if it's their parents
who say don't do this they decide I'm
living my life and so having that as a
recurring theme I find really helps so
follow the Quincy Jones rule remind
yourself that you're great on your own
and you don't do anything because of
somebody else's approval or opinion and
the third thing I remind myself of is be
a tree you're a tree what does a tree do
a tree breathes in Poison for humans
carbon dioxide right Breeze it in Breeze
it in eats it grows from it and then
spits out oxygen positivity for the
world and so I think that our role as
entrepreneurs is actually to eat that
negativity this is your job your job is
to eat the negativity eat the hatred eat
the doubters eat the people who are
complaining and say I'm going to create
something better here's what I'm going
to do and then you go off and do it you
take that you eat it you grow from it
and you create this amazing product or
service that has a big impact and then
what you're doing is you spread hope you
spread possibility you spread belief
that other people can look to you and
say man look look at what that person
did look at what she did look at what he
did I can do the same thing I want to
take a shot on myself too even the
willingness to try is an inspiration
even if you don't make it even if you
don't build some huge business just the
fact that you're willing to try is an
inspiration to other people and so when
I see the negativity when I see people
hating on my ideas when I see people
saying that that's never going to work
out I tell myself I'm a tree bring it
this is the best bring it give it more
give it I'm going to eat all that I'm
going to grow from it I want it to be
public so other people can see
negativity coming at it and here's how
I'm going to react to it and here's the
product service that I'm going to create
spread more positivity spread more
oxygen spread more belief you're a tree
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three figured out
you're who if you want to stop living
the life that other people want for you
you have to understand your most
important core value I call it your who
it's from my book built to serve and
when you figure it out it gives you the
freedom to start living the life that
you actually want to live decisions
become easier life becomes easier and
your confidence starts to Skyrocket and
I'm going to tell you how to do it in
this video so my who is believe my one
word is believe it comes from my parents
they're here on my wall behind me I'm
I'm eight or nine years old in this
picture and my parents are above me and
they would always tell me I'm Evan
Castell carmichel that I can do anything
that I believe that I can my favorite
movie is seab biscuit which is about
this horse that is too small and a
jockey that's too big and an owner that
has no money and somehow they all come
together in the middle of the depression
to to create this amazing story I love
cheering for the under talk I love the
idea that if you just believe in
yourself more you're going to be able to
create amazing things and so believe is
my one word most important core value
it's my who so once you figure that out
it gives you Clarity over everything
else in in my life so look at the videos
that I make it's always positive all my
videos are always positive I always try
to inject believe into everything that I
do into this video right now right here
that you're watching hey what's up
YouTube welcome thank you for watching I
always try to make it about belief now I
may not achieve it I may not have done a
good job you may not be feeling believe
after watching this but it's always my
intention going in it's why I don't have
negative videos if I did the top 10
stupidest things that Jordan Peterson
had said or the top 10 fights between
Kanye and whoever that would actually
blow up more that would that would blow
up more people would rather consume
negativity than positivity I just don't
want to make that video It Doesn't fill
me up it's not my purpose it's not why
I'm here creating the content that I'm
creating and so when you figure out what
your one word is when you figure out
what your who is your most important
core value it allows you to stay on the
path to create the life that you want so
if you come to me with an opportunity
that is not about believe it's an easy
no where otherwise it's hm should I do
it I don't know the money might be good
but it feels a little gross right it's
an easier decision path and if you're
bringing people in to join your team you
now know what you're looking for I need
people who can yes Video Edit hey
Christina but I also need people who
believe and believe right who want to
help other people out so having that
Clarity gives you the rock to stand on
because you're going to be pulled in a
million different directions right your
parents want you to do something your
friends want you to do something the
news want you to do something the people
around you are all telling you do this
and do this and do this and it's like
you don't know what to do and you see
somebody with confidence somebody who's
off chasing their dream and it's easier
just to say well I'm going to go and
follow that person where you could be an
amazing leader yourself the only thing
missing is you don't know what you stand
for when you figure out you're who
you've got the rock to stand on when
everybody else is on quicksand and
drowning you're on your rock and you
know what you need to do okay so what
are the five questions you need to ask
yourself to find your one word most
important core value your who you got A
Sneak Peek it's in my book built to
serve I'm going to I'm going to find it
we're going to go through them together
you can get the book if you want to go
super detailed on it but we're going to
turn in here hold on it's coming we're
going to turn in here to page 20
together I call these the five essential
questions okay so all of the good things
that have happened in your life are
connected all the things that you love
the most about your life are connected
and when you figure out what that
connection is that's your who that's
your most important core value that's
what you value more than other things
and now that you have Clarity over that
you can project your life going forward
and attract those things into your life
as a opposed to having uncertainty and
and lack of clarity and just hoping that
good things happen so here are the five
essential questions okay number one who
is your favorite teacher growing up and
why right who was your favorite teacher
growing up and why number two what is
your favorite movie of all time number
three what do you love most about how
your parents raised you number four
which successful person do you look up
to and why and number five what lessons
do you want your kids to learn from you
right either your current kids if you
have them or your future kids asking
those five questions when you figure out
the answer to those five questions it's
super powerful and I just kind of
highlighted them right now but in the
book it goes into way more detail it's
super powerful because you think well
what is what does my favorite teacher is
have to do with what my favorite movie
is has to do with what I want to teach
my kids everything everything what do I
want to teach my kids believe what do I
teach my son Hayden believe what movies
do I love about believe what do I learn
from my parents belief right and so if
you answer those five questions and you
just come up with three uh words for
each one you'll see that there is some
common thread there is some commonality
and there's a reason why you gravitate
towards that teacher not because they
taught you grade n science because they
made you a better person why what in
that did they make you better at that's
the thing that you still need right now
today just on a bigger scale and so
answering those questions and seeing
what words keep coming up over and over
and over again that's at the essence of
who you are of who you want to be that's
the the best version of you that's your
who that's your one word most important
core value and it's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
in your life rule number four change
your perspective the difference between
you hating and loving your life is
perspective as Marcus reia said the
impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
that negative situation that you're
facing right now will Define you either
you succumb to it and you hate your life
forever or you rise above it and it
becomes the greatest blessing of all
time the choice is yours and I'm going
to show you how to conquer it so you may
have noticed that I have this armband on
this really colorful armband what's the
story I have this on as a reminder to
stay in a beautiful state it's a
reminder to myself every day now
naturally I'm I'm pretty optimistic and
happy and positive and I've trained and
worked on myself to be even more
optimistic and happy and positive and
cons assume things that make me even
more happy and optimistic and positive
but there's still sometimes that I feel
negative there's still times that I'm
not proud of myself the classic example
for me is when I get interrupted if I'm
working on something and I'm in the zone
and I'm focused and I'm building
momentum and somebody interrupts me I
can be really short I can be really rude
I'm not going to say anything offensive
or or something that I would regret but
I could be I could be short and rude and
I want to I want to change that I don't
want anything to knock me out of my
beautiful state at least that's my
ambition that's my intention that's my
goal if I can get closer to it I'll be
pumped it's the perspective shift and so
part of my daily routine is I put this
on I don't I don't sleep with this on uh
at night I'll take it off and then part
of my morning routine is I'll put this
on and and it's a reminder as I put it
on that I want to stay in a beautiful
state today that I might get interrupted
but I want to be proud of how I deal
with it and then I look at it every day
it's hard not to right it's not just
some little tiny you know wristband it's
some it's it's Giant and it's colorful
and it stands out and it's a reminder
every day as I'm typing I see it that oh
yeah yeah yeah beautiful say let's go it
also something that when I'm talking to
people they'll ask me about it because
it's a conversation piece why am I doing
it right people are curious they want to
know and so every time somebody asks me
about it it's a chance to tell the story
again and in telling that story even now
as I'm telling this story it reinforces
for me this is why I have it on this is
why I'm doing what I'm doing and so
having some kind of trigger that brings
that up it really works for me I think
it could work for you as well but
there's a three-step process that I
follow that I'm going to teach you that
I hope helps step number one is
understand that your purpose comes from
your pain this thing that you're
struggling with if it's if it's
overwhelming and allc consuming and
really negative is actually probably the
greatest gift of all time like your
purpose comes from your pain the thing
that you struggled with the most in life
the most in life will be the thing that
you help people with for the rest of
your life I love helping entrepreneurs
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur if I didn't struggle as
much as an entrepreneur I wouldn't be
doing this I'd be doing something else
the thing that saved me from my business
from the worst day when I told my
partner that I quit the thing that saved
me kept me going was I modeled success I
looked at Bill Gates how he started his
company because he was software I was
software I learned from him and I
started growing my company that was when
I was 20 years old I'm almost 40 20
years later now what do I teach people
how to model success for the past 20
years I've helped how many how many
people I don't know 300 million people
Plus have seen my content across my
channels that's a crazy number all
because I suffered when I was 19 20
years
old your purpose comes from your pain
the point of having that pain is not to
just sit in that pain and say wo is me
and complain about it and feel like your
life is over no the the point of that is
to see man I suffered so much here I
want to stop suffering for other people
there's lots of people who are currently
feeling like the way you used to feel
think about who you were a year ago 3
years ago 5 years ago think about the
worst moment of your life whenever that
was there's lots of people who are
currently feeling like that and you can
help them you can save them that's your
purpose and doing that will lift you up
for the rest of your life it will never
get old remember your purpose comes from
your pain Step number two is have play
bigger triggers play bigger triggers are
things in your environment that remind
you to step up into the world that you
want to become a part of that keep you
from staying in the same Zone you're in
that step up to the next level and so I
like having things in my environment and
encourage you to do so as well because
you might have the greatest day of all
time but you wake up tomorrow and feels
like you're starting over from scratch
you're starting over from the beginning
but when you set up your environment it
creates that trigger every day having
Steve Jobs here and AP janini my
favorite entrepreneur my parents and
Howard Schultz and Kanye West behind me
I set that up once but it's a reminder
every day when I walk into my office I
walk into my office I'm looking at my
computer I'm working working like I got
Steve Jobs staring me down right I got
Steve Jobs looking at me I got AP genini
here I got right I walk in and these
people are staring me down they're
looking they're REM Evan let's go let's
go right it's a reminder to me and maybe
that sounds crazy but what is it for you
what's the thing for you what's your
play bigger trigger that you can set up
once in your environment and then it
happens every single day this is a play
bigger trigger right why do I have this
it's a play bigger trigger to remind
myself to live in a beautiful state
every day so if you're thinking about
your physical environment is a great
place right your office your bedroom uh
your car like your physical environment
where are you hanging out a lot in and
what can you put there as a reminder to
play bigger every day your your physical
body right I wear this t-shirt look at
this t-shirt right a bird sitting on a
tree is never afraid of the branch
breaking because her trust is not in her
in the branch but in her wings believe
in yourself right I wear this like I I
love wearing I wear my stuff for me it's
a reminder every day when I'm putting
this on and it's this shirt or the rebel
shirt or the believe shirt I've got a
mannequin right behind the camera of of
my uh my hoodie on a mannequin cuz I I
feel like I'm a superher every time I
put on the believe clothing and so when
I saw a green arrow they had the the the
mannequins wearing the outfits and so I
wanted to have it in M let me just I'll
show you I'll show you look let's make
this quick cuz this thing is heavy this
look at this thing this is this is this
is giant huh this is bigger than life
siiz look it's bigger than me this thing
is taller than me and it just hit me in
the face so this I have this in my
office right right behind the
camera and and I look at it I'm a
superhero what I do is superhero work
this is a reminder it's a play bigger
trigger that thing is heavy
so physical environment right what you
wear on your body right and then also I
think about your screen time so what's
on the backround of your desktop
computer what's on the backround of your
cell phone things that you're looking at
every day that when you see it it's a
reminder I need to step up I need to
play bigger and that's that's different
for everybody maybe the statue means
nothing to you certainly having a
picture of my parents on your wall you
know means nothing to you but if you can
find the things that you set up once
that make you feel like you come alive
and put that in your environment and you
look at it every day it'll it'll force
you to think bigger it'll pull you into
a different level even though the rest
of your environment you can't control
maybe where you're living or your
community or a bunch of other stuff
right now but you can't control that if
you do that it'll pull you up and in set
number three is say it's the best it's
the best this is what I do whenever I
can't control the situation whenever I'm
stuck in something that I don't want to
be a part of then I say it's the best
and where this came from was I was on a
long flight from uh BC to LA speaking at
an an event it's I don't know four or 5
hour flight and I was stuck next to this
really smelly guy and I couldn't get off
the plane cuz I'm going to miss my vent
it's it's a soldout flight so I got
nowhere else to go and I'm stuck next to
this guy and he sank and and I'm sure he
didn't want to stink you know he
probably just had a bunch of layovers
and stopovers and still he's stunk right
and I'm complaining in my head for 8 to
15 seconds and then I tell myself this
is the best because I'm stuck I what's
what's my alternative the alternative is
to be unhappy for the next X number of
hours as I fly to my speaking gig and
then be bad on stage because I've just
spent the last X number of hours being
frustrated said no no no this is the
best and I
turn and I breathe it
in cuz that smelly guy is not stronger
than me and that's what I tell myself in
my head like this situation is not
stronger than me this situation negative
toxic thing that you're involved in
right now that you can't get out of long
term you want you're going to break free
you're going to get out you're going to
do something different but right now you
might be stuck you may have no other
choice it's the best it's the best this
thing is the is what you're most capable
of this that's it you can't handle
anything more I think this is just a
warm-up and so that's what I tell myself
this is the best this is just a warm up
I'm capable of way more this smelly man
does not own me let's go it's the best
rule number five the last one before our
very special bonus clip enjoy the
process and if I had to give advice to
somebody to have success in any field
not just entrepreneurship in any field
you look at the people who have the most
success in any field they enjoy the
process and too many people are attached
just to the outcome if you want to make
a blockbuster hit if you want to make a
successful movie you have to enjoy the
process of making movies as an
entrepreneur if you want to have a
successful product you want to have a
great service that's making a lot of
money you want to have a a huge business
whatever you define as huge or
successful then you need to enjoy the
process of the work that you're doing on
a day-to-day basis and not everything is
going to be amazing you're going to have
down days but net net you have to enjoy
what you're doing you have to wake up
and look forward to the day that is
ahead and too many entrepreneurs are
spending 80 to 90% of their time doing
stuff that they're not good at that they
don't want to be good at that they hate
because they feel they need to do it to
grow their business and only 10 to 20%
of their time on the stuff that they can
be genius level at and you will not have
success in any Endeavor if you're only
spending 10 to 20% of your time or less
on the stuff that you have the potential
to be the best in the world at and that
you enjoy if your goal is just to make a
lot of money and you'll do whatever it
takes just to make that amount of money
you'll never get there because you don't
enjoy the work where the secret to
success is enjoying the daytoday grind
because because it doesn't feel like a
grind it feels
enjoyable you love difficult things you
do difficult things are amazing
difficult things are the best difficult
things are the only way that you grow
think about it what's the opposite of
difficult easy safe inside your comfort
zone boring the single greatest thing
that you can ever do for your confidence
is teach yourself that when things get
difficult you don't shrink down you rise
to the occasion so in my keynote
presentations I used to always use
slides as well I had PowerPoint up and
and I wouldn't read the text off of the
slides but I have a picture and I tell a
story about it and it would always keep
me focused on where my presentation was
going and then I got offered to do a
speaking gig in Paris that was the
keynote speech at this big event for
this software company and I was going to
close the show for them and I had this
idea in my head that what if I didn't do
slides what if I spoke on stage for I
forget how long 45 minutes an hour
closing keynote and I just had one slide
and it was a picture of a rabbit cuz I
was telling a story but trying to teach
a rabbit to climb a tree and it scared
me I thought it's difficult and because
that's what I thought then I had to do
it because in my head is well what if I
don't remember where I go what if I
forget the stories what if I lose track
of where I'm at and I'm sitting here on
stage the closing keynote been paid all
this money to come and I just suck and
because that was the reason then I had
to do it I had to do it and so I said
I'm just going to have one slide and
when the tech team said hey what do you
want to show on screen here it is it's
just one slide yep no videos nope no
audio nope one slide that's it put that
up and I practice and I practice and I
practice and and because my greatest
fear in the world disappointing people I
probably over practice and have my
speech down and I went and and crushed
it but even if I didn't it was the
willingness to to try is the willingness
to do difficult things that as soon as
you feel yourself playing potentially
small based off of something being
difficult that means it's go time that
means you have to do it because teaching
yourself that you think of something
that's big and scary and then you crouch
down and you shy away and you don't do
that that's that's an ongoing lesson
that you are teaching yourself that you
suck you're telling yourself if I went
and said hm what about doing just one
slide in France right from my Paris
keynote what if it's just one slide and
I'm scared of it and I don't do it I'm
teaching myself that I suck that's what
you do anytime you approach something
big and you don't do it you're telling
yourself you're not keepable you're
you're telling yourself that you suck
and so everybody else might let you off
the hook you may not even tell anybody
else about this crazy idea that you have
but you playing small is not acceptable
when something is difficult you have to
attack it head on now I've got a
three-step process that I'll think will
help you take on difficult challenges
step number one is watch your language
anytime you hear yourself saying
difficult scary or hard that means it's
go time why are you not doing the big
things in your life well it's difficult
it's scary it's hard that's not an
acceptable answer nope not anymore not
for you you love difficult you do scary
you Embrace hard it's the best all of it
right so anytime you hear yourself
Talking your thoughts you know in your
head why you're not doing something or
you actually hear it coming out of your
voice you can even tell your friends
your family your co-workers the people
around you say anytime that I say
difficult scary or hard or I want you to
catch me I want you to grab my arm and
say you just said
scary and use that as a trigger go time
this is go time because most of the
things you're afraid of are just
disappointing people it's failing in
front of people it's your thing not
working out yes don't go jumping from
your balcony because it's it's scary
right like be safe but most of the
things that you're afraid of are not
actually life-threatening most of the
things that you are afraid to take on
are not actually life-threatening and so
it's go time difficult scary hard not
acceptable anymore in your vocabulary
when you hear yourself say that think
that feel that you have to go take
action step number two is tell yourself
that this is just a warm-up anytime you
are facing a difficult situation remind
yourself this is just the warm-up when
you feel like you're stretched to the
max when you feel like you can't handle
anymore just that mindset shift to say
this is just a warm-up I'm capable of
way more than this this is not my Max
effort I Can Do Better puts you in a
state of resourcefulness that will allow
you to do more people use this in a gym
as an example so when they're going to
the gym and and they're they're you know
they're pushing weights or they're on
their bike when they feel the feed when
they feel that it's over if you just
tell yourself this is just a warm-up
this is just a warmup I can do way more
than this what it does is allow you it
tricks your brain it allows you to push
an extra set it allows you to go an
extra 5 10 15 minutes on the bike it
allows you to push harder because you're
telling yourself that you're capable of
more the same thing applies to your
business goals to your personal goals to
your life when it's getting difficult
when you're on stage and your PowerPoint
dies when you're faced with this crazy
situation that is outside your control
tell yourself this is this is just a
warm-up I'm just getting started I'm
capable of way more than this and step
number three is it's the best because
difficulties actually are the best
because that thing that you're
struggling with so much will become a
story will become the thing that you tie
your identity to Mel Robbins being on
stage in our PowerPoint failing and then
having to do five extra minutes without
any power becomes a story it becomes the
best the challenges that you go through
become the best become the path that you
can then help other people through
humans are built to serve well how you
going to serve you're going to serve the
people who are facing the same
difficulties that you faced and so
without going through difficulties
you're not going to be able to serve to
the fullest capacity and so the
challenges that you're going through
right now are the best you want the
challenges you don't want the boring
life and so teach yourself this is the
best this nasty problem that I'm going
through through right now that I
wouldn't wish upon my enemy I wouldn't
wish upon you know anybody in my life
it's the best let's go and it may not
actually be you know the best right now
whatever you're dealing with but even
just that mindset trick to say this is
the best it puts you in a state of
resourcefulness so that you can go
handle the problem so you can make
yourself proud because that negative
toxic difficult situation that you are
facing right now will Define you will
Define you either you succumb to it and
you never get back off the mat and do it
again or you rise above it and then you
help all these other people rise above
it as
well because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebr celebration if you
put a # believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome and if you want to watch Evans
top 10 rules for Success check out the
video next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
so on the business side I would say you
have to learn how to figure out how to
bring value to people so doing what you
love is not enough but chasing strategy
alone isn't enough either so a
successful business comes from mixing
what you love